Je m'appelle à Aruinbold.
Je suis le petit médecin
du district de Baruunbayan-Ulaan,
qui se trouve tout au nord
du désert de Gobi.
En Mongolie, il y a des grands
et des petits médecins.
Le petit, c'est l'homme du terrain.
Il n'a que trois années d'études,
mais il doit savoir tout faire.
Tenez les chiens.
Gardez vos chiens.
Ouvrez bien la bouche.
Elle bouge.
Est-ce que vous avez une pince ?
À la campagne, il n'y a pas
de dentiste avec du matériel,
alors je dois tout faire.
J'essaye d'arracher les dents tout seul.
J'utilise les moyens
que je trouve chez les gens.
Donne-nous un peu de vodka.
Tiens la tête de ton oncle.
Je vais lui arracher sa dent.
Je vais l'attraper maintenant.
Un petit peu en arrière.
Si j'avais des anesthésiques,
je ferai une injection.
Mais je n'en ai pas.
Il y a des cas difficiles.
De toute façon, cela fait mal.
Si on la garde, on a mal.
Et si on l'enlève, on a mal aussi.
Votre pince n'accroche pas.
Mais j'ai quand même réussi
à la faire bouger.
Il y a encore une racine
qui tient le choc.
La dent est difficile à avoir
parce qu'elle est rongée des deux côtés.
Et la pince n'est pas bonne.
Maintenant, il a moins mal.
Si ça recommence, il faudra
qu'il aille au village.
Mon district, s'étend vers le sud
sur près de 70 km,
et vers le nord sur une trentaine.
Nous sommes des nomades.
Les familles vivent à 2
ou 3 km les unes des autres,
pour les plus proches,
mais le plus souvent, elles sont
éloignées de 30 à 40 kilomètres.
J'ai sous ma protection un peu
plus de 500 personnes.
Les nomades installent leur yourte
aux rares endroits,
où ils trouvent quelques brins
d'herbe pour leurs troupeaux.
Les kilomètres entre chaque campement
Aruinbold les connaît bien. Il est né ici.
C'est à la fin de ses études qu'il a
accepté de devenir le médecin du Gobi.
Mes parents sont d'ici.
C'est mon pays.
Aucun médecin ne voulait
venir dans le Gobi.
Le médecin général m'a appelé.
Il m'a dit :
"Il n'y a personne
pour aller là-bas,
il faut que vous retourniez
dans votre pays."
Et depuis neuf ans, Aruinbold
est le petit médecin du Gobi,
c'est lui qui prodigue les soins
sur place dans les yourtes.
Il rend visite à tout le monde
au moins une fois par mois.
Quand je rentre dans une yourte, je n'ai
pas à demander à boire ou à manger.
C'est la tradition chez les nomades,
d'offrir à celui qui arrive.
Dans la casserole, de l'alcool de lait.
À peine 30 degrés.
Dans le Gobi, il semble que
ce soit suffisant pour l'asepsie.
Cette femme a travaillé toute sa vie.
Elle a trait les chèvres,
elle a mal au dos.
Avec la ventouse,
j'attire son mauvais sang,
je lui fais la boule.
Ensuite je vais sortir ce mauvais sang
et les gens ont moins mal,
ça leur fait du bien.
Comme du temps de Molière,
le bon vieux remède de la saignée,
pour éliminer le mauvais sang.
C'est le couteau avec lequel
je fais la castration du bétail.
Et il coupe bien.
Il est un peu rouillé, il faut le nettoyer,
mais il est très solide.
Après, je perce avec la pointe 2 ou 3
entailles pour faire sortir le mauvais sang.
Si le sang ne vient pas,
il faut que tu reperces.
Un peu de crème de lait
de chameau pour la cicatrisation.
Un bout de papier journal et un bon coup
de salive en guise de pansement.
Ça me fait beaucoup de bien
contre les maux de tête.
Notre médecin est très bon.
Tout le monde le respecte ici.
Il a vraiment de très bonnes
méthodes thérapeutiques.
Le petit médecin Aruinbold
est lui aussi nomade.
Lui aussi a un troupeau,
mais il n'est pas riche.
Il n'a pas de chameaux,
seulement des chèvres.
Lui aussi vit sous une yourte.
Qui a dessiné ça ?
La première fois que j'ai rencontré
ma femme, elle m'a plu tout de suite.
Nous nous sommes mariés
en 1989 et après cela,
nous avons eu deux garçons.
Manal le plus grand est né en 92.
Timour, le plus petit, en 94.
Ma femme préfère le grand
et moi le petit.
Mais j'ai tout à fait l'intention
de lui faire une fille.
Cela ferait très plaisir à ma femme.
Oui, j'aimerais bien avoir
une fille maintenant.
On appelle souvent Ariunbold en urgence,
et il disparaît pendant plusieurs jours.
Il me dit qu'il va visiter les malades.
Ce matin-là, Aruinbold doit aller jusqu'au
dispensaire de la sous préfecture,
pour renouveler son stock de médicaments
et toucher son salaire.
La sous préfecture, le premier village
à 70 kilomètres de chez lui.
Partout où l'on passe, on voit des ossements.
Ce sont les squelettes des animaux
qui ont été mangés par les loups.
Pour aller au village,
il me faut une bonne journée.
J'y vais environ une fois par mois.
En 70 km de routes, il a droit à tout
ce qui fait le désert de Gobi,
les pierriers, les dunes.
Les dunes épuisent les chevaux,
surtout les jeunes.
Ceux qui sont capables d'aller vite sur
plus de 2 km là-dedans sont très rares.
On ne rencontre pas beaucoup de chevaux des
steppes qui sachent bien galoper dans le sable.
Pour arriver au village, il doit
traverser cinq kilomètres de sable,
avant de retrouver un sol
plus ferme et une piste.
Au bout de cette piste, Baruunbayan-Ulaan,
la sous préfecture.
Un village d'une centaine de yourtes
entourées de palissades,
pour les protéger du vent
et quelques bâtiments administratifs.
2 h d'électricité le soir grâce
à un générateur poussif.
Le plus grand bâtiment
est le dispensaire.
Je suis fonctionnaire.
Étant donné l'état des finances
nationales, je gagne 230 francs par mois.
À quoi ça correspond ?
J'ai besoin de bottes.
Une paire de bottes, c'est 200 francs.
Les gens ne payent
pas mes consultations,
par contre, ils doivent payer,
les médicaments depuis la fin du communisme.
Je les achète à la pharmacie,
et je les revends au prix
où je les ai achetés.
Je ne fais aucun profit.
À chacun de ces passages, Aruinbold
fait le plein de médicaments,
il les revend à l'unité.
Les prix sont très bas.
Reste de cette époque communiste.
Sur le chemin du retour, une rivière,
la seule eau de tout le district.
C'est la seule rivière de la région.
C'est la seule source qui permette
d'abreuver le bétail.
Avec l'arrivée de l'hiver,
elle va se transformer en glace.
En hiver, nous sommes obligés
d'aller dans les montagnes.
Plus haut, avec la neige, il y a de l'eau
pour les hommes et le bétail.
Cette recherche de l'eau a toujours
obligé les habitants du Gobi à se déplacer.
C'est dans les montagnes
qu'ils trouvent refuge l'hiver.
Dolgore, la grisonnante
comme on l'appelle,
la plus âgée de la région.
Dans quelques jours, elle va partir
pour la montagne avec sa famille.
Aruinbold la visite toujours
avec un brin d'émotion.
Chez les nomades, un principe :
Tout le monde doit pouvoir
se débrouiller seul.
La grand-mère Dolgore refuse
de faillir à la règle.
Alors la grisonnante, ça va bien ?
Vous me reconnaissez ?
C'est Aruinbold !
La santé, ça va ?
Je vais vous aider.
Allez, je vous porte.
La vieille, est-ce que
les jambes et les mains, ça va ?
La plus vieille,
c'est la grand-mère Dolgore.
Elle a 106 ans.
Elle possède encore toute sa tête.
Elle est intelligente.
Laquelle de vous oreilles
est la mieux ?
La moyenne d'âge en Mongolie
est de 60 ans.
Dans le désert de Gobi,
il n'y a pas de statistiques,
mais elle doit être inférieure malgré
la longévité de la grand-mère Dolgore.
Le salaire d'Aruinbold
n'est pas suffisant.
C'est son troupeau qui lui permet
d'assurer la survie de sa famille.
Il est l'un des plus pauvres
de tous les éleveurs de la région.
Il ne possède qu'une centaine
de chèvres et trois chevaux.
Quand les siens sont fatigués,
il en emprunte à ses voisins.
Celui-là est un jeune cheval.
Il ne peut pas parcourir
de grandes distances.
Il n'est pas assez formé,
il fatigue vite.
Et il ne faut pas lui enlever trop
de ses réserves pour l'hiver.
Nous ne le savons pas à cet instant,
mais le cavalier qui arrive,
cherche Aruinbold depuis 4 h.
De yourte en yourte,
il a fini par localiser le médecin.
Tu rentres ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Il faut qu'on y aille.
En fait, le jeune garçon
est tombé de cheval.
On se dépêche.
Le cheval qu'on lui prête est plus frais.
Impatient même,
lui ne sait pas qu'il part
pour 30 kilomètres de galop.
De temps en temps l'allure ralentit
pour que les chevaux récupèrent.
Enfin, après 2h30 de course agitée,
le campement où se trouve le petit malade.
Bonjour à tous.
Le jeune malade a douze ans
et s'appelle Orthirbia.
Il vit dans cette yourte avec
ses parents et ses grands-parents.
Toute la famille, trois générations,
une douzaine de personnes.
La mère d'Orthirbia
a deux autres enfants.
C'est moi qui l'ai trouvé en crise.
Comment vas-tu ?
Comment te sens-tu ?
Il a la tête qui lui fait mal.
Comment es-tu tombé de cheval ?
C'est à cause de son père.
Il est parti avec lui.
Qu'est-ce qui t'arrive mon petit ?
Qu'est-ce que tu as ?
Il est très chaud.
Il a un peu de fièvre. Il faudrait lui
mettre quelque chose de frais sur le crâne.
Ce serait mieux qu'on l'emmène
au dispensaire.
Les crises sont trop rapprochées.
Il vaudrait mieux l'emmener au village.
Ça devient dangereux.
Il faut lui faire
des examens plus sérieux.
Il va s'épuiser et il risque de mourir.
On ne pourra pas le transporter
avant deux jours.
On m'a dit qu'il y a une voiture
qui va passer, mais pas avant.
Mon fils, c'est de votre faute.
Personne ne fait attention à lui.
Mon fils, pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
allé chercher le médecin plus tôt ?
On va faire comme ça. On va l'attacher
avec moi derrière mon cheval,
et je vais l'emmener au village.
Voir Aruinbold partir pour
6 ou 7 h de cheval,
le jeune malade ficelé dans son dos
était inacceptable.
Nous avons mis notre véhicule
tout terrain à sa disposition.
Comment vas-tu maintenant ?
Tu as mal à la tête ?
Ouvre la bouche.
Mâche.
Où est-ce qu'on le met ?
Je vous laisse mon cheval, vous
n'aurez qu'à le ramener chez moi.
Je vais m'assoir juste derrière toi.
Reste tranquille.
Le village et son dispensaire se trouvent
à près de 2 h de piste du campement.
Où est la piste ?
- On passe par où ?
- Par le haut.
Effectivement, quelques kilomètres
plus loin, une piste.
C'est assez grave.
Heureusement qu'on peut utiliser
cette voiture pour l'emmener.
Il est épileptique.
Quand il était petit,
il faisait déjà des crises,
dès le berceau.
Il avait des problèmes cérébraux,
des petites déficiences.
Il louchait beaucoup.
Aujourd'hui, il est urgent
de l'emmener à l'hôpital.
Les parents d'Orthirbia
ont des responsabilités.
Ils ont trop attendu avant de m'appeler.
On l'emmène au dispensaire.
Mais on devra peut être
l'emmener à l'hôpital provincial,
à 120 km d'ici.
La jeune femme au manteau,
c'est le grand médecin.
Nous sommes venus en voiture et durant
le trajet, ça s'est amélioré.
Je lui avais donné
quelques médicaments.
Non, il a des rictus, des convulsions
au niveau de la bouche, sur ce côté.
Oui, surtout de ce côté là.
Vers la fin octobre, les familles
commencent leur montée,
vers les lieux d'hivernage.
Pour cette transhumance, tout le monde
donne un coup de main aux voisins.
L'homme au chapeau s'appelle Bata, 32 ans,
comme Aruinbold, son copain d'enfance.
Aujourd'hui encore, son meilleur ami.
Sa yourte de pâturage,
lui sert à suivre son troupeau,
au cours de sa tranquille
montée vers l'hivernage.
Régulièrement, Bata déménage pour ne pas
s'éloigner de ses chèvres et ses moutons,
qui grignotent les dernières
herbes de la vallée.
Bata est riche. Il est propriétaire
de quelques chameaux.
Si c'est un mal, un chameau
peut porter jusqu'à 500 kilos,
mais là, il ne porte
pas plus de 200 kilos.
4-5 kilomètres plus loin, la yourte
est remontée en une demi-heure.
Ce matin là, il pleut
sur le désert de Gobi.
Pas franchement un temps
à mettre le nez dehors,
mais Bata est venu chercher
Aruinbold pour une urgence.
Vu le froid qu'il fait là-haut,
il doit neiger.
Bata a appris qu'une petite fille
est malade dans la montagne.
Ses parents craignent une appendicite.
Il a décidé d'accompagner Aruinbold.
Quand les nomades s'éparpillent dans les
montagnes, cela complique mon travail.
Il faut que je me rende loin
à cheval dans la neige.
C'est plus difficile mais
je n'ai pas le choix.
Quand faut y aller, il faut y aller !
Ce défilé et la route la plus courte
et la plus rapide pour y accéder.
Dans cette montagne,
on régénère sa force vitale.
Quand on passe le col de Roc.
Les gens d'ici disent que
l'on gagne trois années de vie.
Le col de Roc
à 2800 mètres d'altitude,
600 mètres en contrebas,
une vallée avec des arbres.
Les familles qui viennent ici trouvent
du bois pour passer l'hiver.
Quand on m'appelle d'urgence,
que quelqu'un est malade,
je ne sais jamais combien
de temps ça me prendra.
Il arrive souvent que je parte
pour 2 ou 3 jours.
Ça fait deux jours
qu'elle a mal au ventre,
et quand je lui demande où,
elle montre ici.
Ne pleure pas,
je vais juste regarder un peu.
Elle a effectivement
le ventre un peu gonflé.
C'est l'estomac, pas l'appendicite.
Est-ce que vous lui avez
donné des médicaments ?
Vous n'avez pas de médicaments ?
Ouvre la bouche.
Tu es une bonne petite fille.
Ouvre bien.
Écoutez-moi.
Demain matin, on lui fait prendre
l'autre moitié de ce médicament.
Et 30 minutes plus tard,
vous lui donnerez,
un demi cachet de chacun
de ces deux là.
La plupart du temps, les nomades n'ont
pas d'argent. Je leur fais crédit,
ils me paient quand ils peuvent
et comme ils peuvent.
Il arrive qu'ils me paient
bien plus tard.
Mais je préfère qu'ils me payent avec
une peau de chèvre ou de mouton.
Une nuit au chevet de la petite fille.
Le lendemain matin, il y avait
une nouvelle couche de neige.
L'année dernière, à la même époque,
la neige était déjà tombée 3 ou 4 fois.
Cette année, elle est très en retard.
Cela veut dire que l'hiver
va être très froid.
Il fait aux alentours de -10 degrés.
En hiver, les chevaux mongols devinent
où se trouve la nourriture.
Ils sont habitués à avoir soif et faim.
Il n'y a pas un endroit
qui ne puisse pas atteindre.
La peau a gelé ?
Non, elle est toute fraîche.
Cours de la peau de chèvres
dans le Gobi,
2000 tugrik, 20 francs,
le prix des médicaments qu'il a
laissé aux parents de la petite fille.
Bon diagnostic du docteur.
Au petit matin, la jeune malade
va nettement mieux.
Ici, il y a beaucoup d'animaux,
des bouquetins, des mouflons,
des léopards des neiges, des loups.
Pour l'instant, les loups, ça va.
En hiver et au printemps,
ils deviennent plus dangereux.
L'incroyable résistance
des petits chevaux mongols.
Grâce à eux, Gengis Khan et les ancêtres
de Bata et d'Aruinbold avaient conquis,
il y a sept siècles, le plus grand empire
que la terre ait jamais connu.
Quoi que l'on regarde les montagnes,
les prés ou le bétail,
il faut que ce soit beau.
C'est de cela que nous, les
Mongols, tenons notre paix.
Retour à la maison après
deux jours de voyage.
La neige qui était également tombée dans
la vallée a eu le temps de fondre.
Mais qu'ils sont moches
ces deux horribles animaux !
Qui sont ces 2 animaux si laids ?
Non, ça ce n'est pas une peau de loup !
Qu'as-tu sur le bout du nez ?
Vas-y, rentre-la.
Au revoir mon ami.
Dis au revoir à Bata.